Цього разу програма Conflict Zone - у Відні,
і ми поговоримо з міністеркою
закордонних справ Австрії Карін Кнайссль.
На цей пост її висунула правопопулістська Австрійська партія свободи,
яка виступає проти міграції. Попри те, що
сама Карін Кнайссль не належить до цієї партії.
Ласкаво просимо у програму Conflict Zone.
Дякую.
Президент Володимир Путін - близький союзник
сирійського президента Башара Асада - масового вбивці, вбивці свого ж народу.
На совісті їх обох - життя сотень тисяч мирних громадян.
Як ви оцінюєте роль Путіна в цьому пеклі?
Kоли Росія розпочала втручатися в Сирію, це було...
офіційною датою було 30 вересня 2015 року.
Ісламська держава, як вона тоді називала себе,
рухалась в бік Латакії, і я дуже добре пам'ятаю, як
спецпредставник ООН Стаффан де Містура
попереджав про масовий вихід з Латакії, якщо ІД почне там різанину...
А тепер замість ІД масові вбивства здійснює Асад за повної підтримки Росії.
Зараз у нас 2018 рік і ми знали, ми бачили,
що відбувається в Сирії за повної підтримки Росії.
Так, але можу я ...
Я знову поставлю своє запитання: як ви сьогодні оцінюєте роль Путіна в цьому пеклі?
Що ми маємо ... у нас є не тільки Путін і Асад в Сирії.
Це війна чужими руками, яка розпочалася влітку 2011-го,
у війні бере участь низка зацікавлених сторін. І Росія - одна з них.
І тому ще раз: як ви оцінюєте роль Путіна в цьому пеклі?
Я розглядаю Росію як партнера в Сирії,
і ми про це неодноразово заявляли.
І це не тільки ми, не тільки я, цю позицію озвучив Європейський Союз.
І під час останнього засідання Ради ЄС тут, у Відні,
на неформальній зустрічі міністрів закордонних справ ЄС два тижні тому,
ми обговорювали, що повинні обирати
прагматичний підхід до спільної роботи з Росією в Сирії ...
Я розумію вашу прагматичну аргументацію.
Але за цією аргументацією дуже важливо зрозуміти ваші цінності.
Тому, по-перше, я думаю, що повинна бути якась конкретна оцінка:
засуджуєте ви чи ні?
І після цього ми зможемо продовжити дискусію.
Ви засуджуєте роль Путіна на Близькому Сході, особливо в Сирії? Так чи ні?
Я не прийшла сюди засуджувати, я...
- Ні?
- Ні...
Сотні й тисячі мирних жителів загинули...
Так, і вони були вбиті різними сторонами.
І Росією теж?
Так, і Росією теж.
І цього не достатньо, щоб засудити Росію?
Чому ви така обережна з Путіним?
Ні, зовсім ні...
Ви запросили президента Росії Володимира Путіна на своє весілля,
яке було минулого місяця, і він приїхав.
Чому ви запросили його? Він ваш друг?
Це вийшло спонтанно. До цього я зустрічалася з ним,
і ми довго обговорювали наші позиції з якихось питань,
в тому числі і ситуацію на Близькому Сході.
Його зацікавив мій аналіз, і коли він був...
І тому він приїжджає на ваше весілля, щоб продовжити обговорення міжнародних проблем?
На вашому весіллі? Тобто це не була приватна зустріч?
Це була приватна зустріч ...
... з розмовами про Сирію?
Зустріч також була дуже нетривалою. Так.
А чому ви не запросили пані Меркель чи пана Макрона?
Я запросила очільника британського МЗС, але в нього не було часу.
Ви танцювали й обіймали пана Путіна. Водночас ви знали, що
він є партнером сирійського диктатора Асада. В них обох руки в крові.
Вас не мучили докори сумління?
Танцювати з людиною, від якої потерпає його ж власне населення.
Вибачте, але в такому випадку, чи повинні ми тиснути руки уряду Китаю?
Чи повинні ми тиснути руки цілій низці урядів, як ви вважаєте?
А ви не думаєте, що є різниця між рукостисканням і
танцем з обіймами в один із найважливіших днів у житті?
Обійми. Я сприймаю це по-іншому, ніж ви. Я не обіймала його. Ми танцювали.
Так. Але до цього я в своєму житті танцювала ще з кількома чоловіками.
Але чи правильний це символ?
Адже це ваше весілля. Який це сигнал для людей, яких переслідують у Росії?
Я розумію, що службовий обов'язок змушує вас вести діалог з різними людьми,
ви змушені спілкуватися навіть із диктаторами. Але це ж ваше весілля і ви з ним танцювали.
Я танцювала з ним. Так.
Росія Володимира Путіна також перебуває під санкціями Євросоюзу,
тому що він анексував український Крим.
Так. І ми засудили це, і наші санкції діють досі.
В Австрії були великі дипломатичні проблеми після цього так званого
''приватного'' візиту Володимира Путіна. Наприклад,
під час візиту канцлера Себастіана Курца в Україну.
Ваш колега, міністр закордонних справ України Павло Клімкін,
назвав запрошення на весілля серйозною помилкою. Ви з цим згодні?
Ні.
Чому?
Тому, що я запросила його і не шкодую про це. І, крім того, був...
єдиний меседж був від Павла Клімкіна, переданий на приватній зустрічі.
А в іншому, щоб ви знали, ніхто з моїх закордонних колег,
із якими в мене були зустрічі буквально через 10 днів після мого весілля,
ніхто з них не говорив, що...
Можливо, це просто дипломатія.
Ні...
Але ви також дуже дипломатична...
Так, і тим не менше, якщо вам щось не подобається, можна про це сказати або ви...
Можна, але зовсім не обов'язково.
Ну, навпаки, я отримала привітання від всіх моїх колег.
Привітання з чим? Що ви станцювали з паном Путіним?
Не знаю, з чим.
Можливо, вітали з весіллям.
Так, уявіть собі.
Євросоюз запровадив санкції проти Росії.
Австрійська партія свободи підтримала анексію Криму і виступає проти санкцій.
Ви підтримуєте позиції цієї партії?
Ми є частиною уряду.
Хто це ми?
Ми - уряд. Я кажу зараз як член австрійського уряду,
і ми - уряд Австрії - сформували нашу коаліцію на умовах тандему з Європейським Союзом
у тому, що стосується режиму санкцій...
Тобто ви згодні з санкціями?
Ну звичайно! Хіба я коли-небудь говорила щось інше?
Карін Кнайссль, дякую, що ви взяли участь у Сonflict Zone. Було приємно познайомитись